let's save something moving with a
constant velocity of five meters per
second and we're just assuming it's
moving to the right just to give us a
direction because this is a vector
quantity so it's moving in that
direction right over there and let me
plot its velocity against time so this
is this is my velocity so I'm going to
actually going to only plot the
magnitude of the velocity and you could
specify that like this so that's the
this is the magnitude of the velocity
and then on this axis I'm going to plot
I am going to plot time so we have a
constant velocity of five meters per
second so it's magnitude is five meters
per second five meters per second and
it's constant it's not changing as the
seconds tick away the velocity does not
change so it's just moving five it's
just five meters per second now my
question to you is how far does this
thing travel after five seconds so after
five seconds so this is one second two
second three second four second five
seconds right over here so how far did
this thing travel after five seconds
well we could think about it two ways
one we know that velocity we know that
we know that velocity is equal to
displacement is equal to displacement
over change in time and displacement is
just change in position over change so
this is change in position over change
in time or another way to think about it
if you multiply both sides by change in
time you get velocity times change in
time is equal to is equal to
displacement so what was the
displacement over here well I know what
the velocity is it's five meters per
second
I know it's five meters per second
that's the velocity let me color code
this that is the velocity and we know
what the change in time here it is five
seconds it is five seconds and so you
get the seconds cancel out the seconds
you get five times five twenty five
meters is equal to twenty five meters
and that's pretty straightforward
but the slightly more interesting thing
is is that's exactly the area under this
rectangle right over here that is
exactly this area right over here now
what I'm going to show you in this video
that is in general if you plot velocity
the magnitude of velocity so you could
say speed versus time or let me just
stay with the magnitude of the velocity
versus time the area under that curve is
going to be the distance traveled
because or the displacement because
displacement is just the velocity times
the change in time so it's just if you
just take out a rectangle right over
there
so let me draw a slightly different one
where the velocity is changing and so
let me draw a situation where you have a
constant acceleration the acceleration
over here is going to be one meter per
second per second so one meter per
second squared and let me draw the same
type of graph all that's going to look a
little different now so this is my
velocity axis give myself a little bit
more space so this is my velocity axis
so I'm just going to draw out the
magnitude of the velocity and this right
over here is my time axis so this is
time let me mark some stuff off here so
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten and one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten and the magnitude
of velocity is going to be measured in
meters per second and the time is going
to be measured in seconds time is going
to be measured in seconds so what's
going to happen here assuming that we
start with so my initial velocity my
initial velocity or I could say the
magnitude of my initial velocity the
magnitude of my initial velocity so just
this my initial speed you could say this
is just a fancy way of saying my initial
speed is zero so my initial speed is
zero so after one second what's going to
happen after one second I'm going one
meter per second faster so now I'm going
one meter per second after two seconds
what's happened well now I'm going
another meter per second faster than
that after another second if I if I go
forward in time if change in time is 1
second then I'm going a second faster
than that and if you remember the
idea of slope from your Algebra one
class that's exactly what the
acceleration is in this diagram right
over here the acceleration we know we
know that acceleration is equal to
change in velocity change in velocity
over change in time over here change in
time is along the x-axis so this right
over here is a change in time and this
right over here is a change in velocity
so in this when we when we plot velocity
or the magnitude of velocity relative to
time the slope of that line is the
acceleration and since the we're
assuming the acceleration is constant we
have a constant slope so we have just a
line here we don't have a curve now what
I want to do is think about a situation
let's say that we accelerated 1 meter
per second squared and we do it for we
do it for so the time so the change in
time is going to be is going to be 5
seconds and my question to you is how
far have we traveled which is a slightly
more interesting question than what
we've been asking so far so we start off
with an initial velocity of 0 and then
for 5 seconds we accelerate at 1 meter
per second squared so 1 2 3 4 5 so this
is where we go this is where we are so
after 5 seconds we know our velocity our
velocity is now 5 meters per second 5
meters per second but how far have we
traveled so we could think about it a
little bit visually we could say look we
could try to draw rectangles over here
we were at maybe right over here we had
a velocity of 1 meter per second so if I
say 1 meter per second times a second
that'll give me that'll give me a little
bit of distance and then the next one I
have a little bit more of distance
calculate it the same way I could keep
drawing these rectangles here but then
you're like wait those rectangles are
missing there you know because I wasn't
for the whole second I wasn't only going
1 meter per second I kept accelerating
so actually I should maybe split up the
rectangles I could split up the
rectangles even more so maybe I go every
half second so on this half second I was
going at this velocity and I go at that
velocity for a half second velocity
times the time will give me the
displacement and then I do it
the next half second same exactly idea
here give me the displacement so on and
so forth well I think what you see is
you're getting is the more accurate your
the smaller the rectangles you try to
make here the closer you're going to get
to the area under this under this curve
the area under this curve and just like
the situation here this area under the
curve is going to be the distance is
going to be the distance traveled the
distance traveled and lucky for us this
is just going to be a triangle and we
know how to figure out the area for a
triangle so the area of a triangle is so
area of a triangle is equal to 1/2 times
base times height which hopefully makes
sense to you because if you just
multiply base times height you get the
area for the entire rectangle and the
triangle is exactly half of that so the
distance traveled in this situation the
distance traveled or I should say the
displacement just because we want to
make sure we're focused on vectors the
displacement here is going to be or I
should say the magnitude of the
displacement maybe which is the same
thing as the distance is going to be 1/2
times the base which is 5 seconds which
is 5 seconds 5 seconds times the height
which is 5 meters per second times 5
meters let me do that in that other
color 5 meters per second 5 meters per
second the seconds cancel out with the
seconds and we're left with 1/2 times 5
times 5 meters so it's 1/2 times 25
which is equal to 12 point 5 meters and
so there's an interesting thing here
well one there's a couple of interesting
things hopefully you realize that if
you're plotting velocity versus time the
area under the curve given a certain
amount of time tells you how far you
have traveled the other interesting
thing is is the slope of the curve tells
you your acceleration what's the slope
over here well where it's completely
flat and that's because the velocity
isn't changing so in this situation we
have a constant acceleration we have a
constant acceleration the magnitude of
that acceleration is exactly zero our
velocity is not changing
here we have a acceleration of one meter
per second squared and that's why the
slope of this line right over here is
one
the other interesting thing is if you
want to even if you have constant
acceleration you can still figure out
the distance by just taking the area
under the curve like this we were able
to figure out that we were able to get
twelve point five meters the last thing
I want to introduce you to actually let
me just do it into the next video and
I'll introduce you to the idea of
average velocity now that we feel
comfortable with the idea that the
distance you traveled is the area under
this the velocity versus time curve